[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Lan piranha and I'll
be your host today so without further
Ado let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together
get ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
learning a
language in this episode we'll delve
deep into the art of language learning
uncovering the fascinating process of
acquiring new tongs and the incredible
benefits that come along with it whether
considering picking up a new language
this episode is sure to pick your
interest the the magic of language
learning let start by acknowledging the
magic of language learning the ability
to communicate in a foreign tongue is
akin to unlocking a new world it's like
stepping through a portal into a
different culture a different way of
thinking the sense of wonder and
Discovery is unparalleled every new word
every phrase you master is a key that
opens doors to understanding connecting
and exploring the world in ways you
might never have
imagined every language you learn opens
up an entirely new universe filled with
unique stories traditions and
experiences knowing another language
enhances every experience travel
traveling enjoying a film or deepening a
friendship with someone from a different
part of the
globe cognitive and brain benefits
now let's talk about the incredible
cognitive benefit of language learning
your brain my friends is like a muscle
and when you learn a new language you're
giving it a through a workout Studies
have shown that bilingual and
multilingual individuals often exhibit
enhance problem solving skes better
memory and even reduced risk of
cognitive decline as they age it is like
your brain is getting a personal trainer
and the results are
impressive it has been shown that people
who speak other languages often exhibit
more empathy and the global mindset
researchers have recorded the sensation
felt by some of being a different person
when speaking their second language
however we can't be sure of what causes
what are people with a global mindset
more likely to wish to learn a language
and more likely to excel in them or is
an interest in the openness to other
culture cultures a result of learning a
language in contrast there is strong
evidence for positive effect of learning
a language on creativity in language use
fluency originality and creative
flexibility are improved in one's first
language when learning a second language
this may be due to the cognitive
practices involved in learning a new
language such such as willingness and
adaptability to change required for a
language speeching or the rigorous
practice and study involved in language
learning but we need more research to
understand how this differs by age and
gender and the learning
strategy culture connections language is
is more than just words it's the key to
understanding and connecting with other
cultures learning a language allows you
to immerse yourself in the Customs
traditions and beliefs of the people who
speak it it Fosters empathy and a deeper
appreciation for
diversity you see the world from a
different perspective and begin to
appreciate the unique beauty of each
languages
expression career and travel
opportunities the Practical benefits of
language learning are immense it opens
doors to career opportunities especially
in our increasingly in interconnected
World bilingual and multilingual
individuals are highly sought of in many
Industries the career benefits of
learning a second language go go well
past having the vocabulary to close a
deal or navigate the dinner menu on your
big business trip language gives you
insight into cultures plus the ability
to speak with someone in their first
language breaks down barriers while
building trust no matter the workplace
or business setting your language skills
will go a long way toward developing
strong
relationships just imagine how you'll
converse with colleagues in your
company's Global offices and ease or
create a personal connection with a
client and let's not forget travel
knowing the Lo local language can
transform your trips from being a
tourist to being an Explorer learning
the basics of the local language will
help you to get around places and make
travel so much easier turning it into a
fun and and memorable experience it can
be a great help whether it's for reading
signs or asking
directions it saves you from the
likelihood of getting lost in a foreign
country apart from that knowing phrases
and words in the local language enables
you to confidently order food in a
restaurant check into a hotel and better
yet negotiate a cheap cheaper price at
the
market it enriches your experiences and
allows you to connect with locals on a
deeper
level personal growth and fulfillment
finally there's the personal growth and
aspects of language learning the journey
isn't always easy but it's immensely
rewarding the sense of accomp
accomplishment when you can hold a
conversation in a new language is
unparalleled it's a testament to your
dedication and your ability to embrace a
challenge it boost your confidence and
self-esteem in all aspects of
life in conclusion the art of language
learning is profound as
transformative Journey it's not just
about words it's about enriching your
mind connecting with others and
exploring the world in a unique
way learning a new language invites you
to new worlds challenges your cognitive
capacities and offer delightful cultural
res
rendo your language learning Journey can
be so much more than route
memorization from tapping into the
rhythmic proces of music and movies to
engaging in hearty real world
conversations and set setting exciting
Milestones each step is a celebration of
progress and
Explorations so whether you're mastering
your third fourth or even your first
language remember that every word you
learn is a step closer to a more
colorful connected and fulfilling life
thank you so much for joining joining us
today on this episode of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
right
until next time take care and
[Music]
bye